[موسيقى]
ازيكم
انا شبهكم وحي
اتي وقصتي شبه قصه كتير قوي منكم انا جنى
اسامه عندي 17 سنه من سنه واحده بس كنت
بحضر الايفنت ده مكانكم بسمع التوكس وحسب
احباط رهيب ان كل الناس دي بتتحرك وانا
واقفه مكاني
قبل ما احضر الايفنت كنت بعدي فتره من
اصعب فترات حياتي مستويات دراسي قال بقيت
حد غير واثق في نفسه ما بقتش العب رياضات
اللي بحبها حتى هواياتي اللي كنت بحب
اعملها ما بقتش بعملها وده خلاني اقصر في
بقيه حاجات في حياتي
فقررت اني هشوف ايه المشكله
صحابي اللي كانوا معايا لمده 11 سنه وكان
اقرب حد ليا بعدنا عن بعض يمكن المشكله
كانت فيا لاني كنت متعلقه بيهم تعلق غير
صحي هسالكم سؤال حد فيكم يعرف هل الاشخاص
اللي في حياتنا ممكن نستبدلهم ولا لا حتى
لو كانوا اهلنا
في الحقيقه هو اه اي شخص في حياتنا او اي
علاقه بندخلها هي ممكن نستبدلها لان الهدف
من اي علاقه هو ان احنا نحس شعور معين
بيديهولنا الشخص ده ولو في شخص بيدينا
اكتر من شعور فده بيبقى صعب الاستغناء عنه
بس في النهايه كلنا يمكن استخدامنا عشان
كده ورغم كده ناس كتير بتتعلق باللي
حواليها تعلق غير صحي وده بيسبب لهم
اضطرابات بيخليهم مش قادرين يتعرفوا على
ناس جديده حتى لو طبيعتي ان انا شخص
اجتماعي وبيتحب يتكلم مع الناس فالتعلق
الغير صحي بيخليني مش قادره اعمل كده عشان
كده اختار صحابك صح اختارهم شبهك بيساعدوك
تحقق الحاجه اللي انت عايزها وتشاركهم في
تفاصيل نجاحك وانت مرتاح ومش حاسس بضغط
نفسي
اتغيرت
اي موقف عديت بيه في حياتي اداني خبره
الخبره دي ساعدتني اني اوصل لاهدافي اللي
مكنتش عارفه هوصل لها ازاي وامتى وازاي
حاجات كتيره ما كنتش متوقعه انها هتعطلني
كانت معطاني في حياتي ما حدش فينا بيبقى
حاسس ان العلاقه دي ازياء لان هو اساسا
بيبقى اتعود عليها حد فيكم راح سوق السمك
قبل كده
بنبقى مستغربين قوي ازاي الناس دي قادرين
يستحملوا ريحه طول اليوم في الحقيقه هم مش
مستحملينها لان هم مش حاسين بها اصلا هم
اتعودوا عليها
بقت يعني طبيعه يومهم ان هم بيشموا الريحه
دي فعشان كده انت مش هتحس ان العلاقه دي
يا زياد غير لما تخرج منها
اول حاجه عملتها اني دعيت ربنا انه يرزقني
حسن اختيار الطريق الصح اللي ابدا فيه
والحمد لله قدرت احضر الايفنت ده السنه
اللي فاتت وشفت ازاي الناس دي كلها عملت
حاجات وان انا كمان اقدر اتغير
كنت بدات اذاكر جبت 98% وده اهني اني اقدم
في ثلاث منح في سنه واحده
[تصفيق]
قدمت في منحه تابعه للجامعه الامريكيه
واتقبلت وقدمت في منحه تابعه لوزاره
الاتصالات وتكنولوجيا المعلومات واتقبلت
وقدمت في منحه تابعه لوزاره الثقافه وبرضو
اتقبلت الحمد لله
لعبت رياضه اللي كان نفسي العبها بس للاسف
بسبب ان كان سني عدى اني اقدر اتميز فيها
واخد بطولات فما قدرتش اكمل وده سبب لي
احباط كبير اني حسيت اني ضيعت الوقت اللي
كان المفروض اكون بعمل فيه حاجه بحبها في
حاجه يعني ما نفعتنيش دلوقتي وده اداني
حافز واخدت قرار ان ما فيش يوم هيعدي غير
لما اعمل انجاز جديد حتى لو كان الانجاز
ده بسيط
بدات اسمع عن حاجه اسمها student acties
دخلت عملت سيرش واللي هو
ولقيت جروبس في الجامعه مع بعض فشاركت في
اول تيم ليا وعملت اول انترفيو ليا في
حياتي واللي يعني مش قادره انسى سعودي في
الانترفيو ده اني حسيت اني بدات انفس في
الحاجه اللي كنت باستناها من زمان
اشتغلت مع 25 اورجانيزيشن في نفس الوقت 25
ب 25 لوجو ب 25 ثيم وفكره كل اورجانيزيشن
من دول محتاجه مجهود لوحده كنت بصحى اعمل
ديزاين عشان افطر اعمل ديزاين ارتاح اعمل
ديزاين اتغدى اعمل ديزاين وهكذا لمده سنه
كامله سنه كامله انا شغاله اني اطور في
الكارير بتاعي
[تصفيق]
بدات بدات الاستوديو اتاكتيفيتس دي تنزل
عني وبقى ناس كتير تبعت لي ان هم عايزيني
امسك لهم البيزنس والتيمز بتاعتهم وده
اداني ثقه كبيره قوي مش نفسي اني اكمل
وعارفين انتم احساس اللي هو
انا يا ابني شكرا على ثقتك الغالية
ههه ده خلاني اطور في مجالي اكتر فاخدت
دبلومه من جوجل في الديجيتال ماركتينج
عشان ابقى عارفه اي حاجه تخص مجالي واللي
هو الجرافيك ديزاين فاخدت في الماركتينج
واخدت الكورسز من منصات معتمده ساعدتني
اني اطور في المجال بتاعي اكتر
وجه بقى المسابقه اللي كان فيها حصاد كل
ده بالنسبه لي انترناشونال ساينس
ايه ده انا هشارك في مسابقه على مستوى
العالم انا كنت قاعده بفكر كده وانا قاعده
على السرير ازاي اربط مجالي بمجال من اللي
له مستقبل دلوقتي ولقيت ان الارتفيشه
من اكتر المجالات اللي لها مستقبل دلوقتي
وجاءت في دماغي فكره بتربط كل المجالات دي
بمجالي فعملت بيساعد اصحاب البيزنس واي حد
عنده تيم لسه بيبدا انه يعمل ديزاين في 50
ثانيه بس حتى لو ما عندوش بجراوند عن
الجرافيك ديزاين وحتى لو هو ما عندوش
جرافيك ديزاينر ده ليه علشان لما يكون
الجرافيك ديزاينر مش موجود الماركتين كان
فين ما تتعطلش
لا لا
شاركت في في المسابقه ورحت اول يوم انا
جرافيك ديزاينر معايا لوجو بروجكت والفكره
في دماغي طبعا قالوا لي ما ينفعش الكلام
ده لازم الفكره تبقى على ارض الواقع قلت
لهم بس انجلاء فيك ديزاين روحت عملت
ديزاين قال للانترفيس بتاع البروجكت
بتاعنا ورحت لهم تاني يوم بس ايه الديزاين
يبقى موضح الفكر والمفاجاه ان الفكره
عجبتهم وادونا مركز تاني على المستوى
الاداره
طبعا يعني اخويا اللي ما كنتش هقدر اوصل
لاي حاجه من دي الا بسببه ساعدني جدا في
المشروع هو حاضر معنا هنا
وتاهلنا على مستوى قطاع شرق القاهره
وبين المعرض والمعرض احنا كنا بنجهز هنعمل
ايه اصلا انا معي بدايه المشروع طب اللي
بعده ايه انا محتاجه المشروع ده يبقى
علشان الناس دي يطلع ريزول ويستفادوا بها
فعلا على ارض الواقع المفروض ان احنا
بنبقى داخلين المسابقه دي بالمشروع اصلا
انما احنا بين كل معرض والتاني كنا بنحضر
احنا هنعمل ايه
شاركنا في معرض قطاع شرق القاهره وطلبوا
مننا تعديلات وعدلناها وشاركنا في معرض
القاهره اللي كان في مدرسه ايفي الدوليه
وبعد كده لقيت ان البرودكت بتاعي اتنفذ
على ارض الواقع كل ده انا ما كنتش هاوصل
له في سنه واحده بس مش هنكر ان اصحابي
تاثيرهم علي ساعدني اني اعمل ده واتحدى
نفسي ان في سنه واحده بس اقدر اعمل كل ده
واقدر اكون موجوده معكم النهارده والحمد
لله
ربنا عوضني في صحاب واقفين في ضهري بجد
علاقتنا ببعض قويه جدا بس الاهم انها بشكل
صحي
خليك مقتنع ان الموضوع صعب بس مش اصعب من
ان انت تبقى واقف مكانك وكل اللي حواليك
بيتحركوا ووقت ما هتكتشف انك كنت بتلعب
وقت ما غيرك كان بيتعب هيكون هو خلاص
اتميز اه الرزق ده بتاع ربنا بس ربنا
بيقول الايه بتقول وانا ليس للانسان الا
ما سعى
احضروا يبانس عن الجامعات واعرفوا ايه
المجالات اللي ليها مستقبل دلوقتي وابدا
يشتغل على نفسك فيها من دلوقتي عشان لما
توصل للمرحله المهمه تبقى مرتاح لانك
اتحركت وانت صغير شكرا لكم